in 2018 a cockroach crawled inside a
sleeping man's ear and laid an egg sac
luckily roaches don't go out of their
way to do this so it doesn't happen very
often but there are a bunch of other
unsavory bugs that will lay eggs all
over your body
on purpose first up the human botfly
these insects which are native to
Central and South America glue their
eggs to mosquitoes and other blood
sucking insects when the mosquito bites
you the eggs hatch then the larvae
wriggle into your skin creating a
painful pimple at least puss or as the
baby bop flies call it lunch after five
to ten weeks they escape not long after
that they reach adulthood ready to mate
and start the cycle all over another
tropical parasite is Tunga penetrance
more commonly known as the sand flea
females burrow into the bottom of your
foot and slurp your blood they start off
smaller than a grain of sand but grow to
2,000 times your size within a week as
they swell with your blood and up to 200
eggs those eggs fall to the ground and
hatch waiting for the next barefoot to
pass by but some egg-laying parasites go
more than just skin deep and tapeworms
for example invade your intestines
adults can grow to be longer than a
bowling lane and block up your digestive
system but it gets worse because they
lie tens of thousands of eggs which can
hatch and migrate spreading throughout
your lungs muscles and even your brain
if that sounds gruesome just wait till
you hear about the low aloha worm it can
be passed from human to human by
hitching a ride inside of deer flies
when the Flies bite you larvae entered
through the wound after five months
growing beneath their skin they reach
adulthood and start to release thousands
of embryos again
sometimes you can even see the worms
moving under your skin or across your
eyeball but hey not every egg-laying
invader is sinister face mites for
example are pretty innocuous they live
on pretty much everyone's face and most
people just never notice after all they
feed on facial oil not flesh when it
comes time to breed females just lay one
egg inside of your pores even better
researchers can now study your face
mites to track how your ancestors
migrated across the planet because we
usually pass them from parent to child
so the mites stay in the family but face
mites aren't the only helpful bug around
green bottle flies might be useful in
medicine they lay their eggs inside of
open wounds and then the mag attached
and devour the damaged flesh that sounds
brutal but one day we might be able to
harness this process to treat diabetic
foot ulcers and other slow healing
wounds because when the maggots go to
town they actually clean the area and
remove a lot of the dead tissue
they even secrete proteins that reduce
inflammation
so maybe bot flies fleas and tapeworms
could learn a thing or two and at least
make themselves useful if they're going
to move right in